foreign
[Music]
I'll preface this by saying that my son
Tim recently got married to his now wife
Sarah we get along just fine as a family
so she tends to act passive aggressively
sometimes she loves food and is always
open to trying my cooking she said my
cooking was amazing though she made few
a few negative comments about certain
meals and advised me to use XYZ
ingredients next time
who are these people
so she sat down to have your meal and
said oh this is great but next time you
should try that ingredient this who does
that
um I invited them over for Thanksgiving
yesterday the whole family was there the
bell rang and I opened the door to see
Tim and Sarah Sarah was carrying what
seemed to be a container I didn't ask
about it nor paid much attention to it
everybody sat down to eat after I set up
the table and put dinner on it my main
dish was the traditional Thanksgiving
dish every family in our community knows
I had appetizers and side dishes and of
course salad and dessert
Sarah then put the container on the
table and started unloading food onto
her empty plate everybody was watching
as my eyes widened up I asked what she
was doing and she said that she brought
her own food to eat since she won't eat
what she doesn't want to eat what I
cooked I was stunned and I politely
asked
if there was a reason for that and she
shook her head
I asked if she was vegan she said no
asked if she was allergic to anything at
the table she said no I asked if she if
she was having an upset stomach or
anything she said no uh she just sat
with a smug smile and uh which set me
off and then anyway okay then it goes on
and on and on and uh the this ungrateful
daughter-in-law eats her own meal at the
table while the son just sits there okay
so yeah um Sarah is an [ __ ] but I put
the blame on your son Tim really I think
he's the bigger Apple here because what
kind of husband allows his wife to bring
a tupperware container with her own meal
to his parents Thanksgiving dinner
I mean there are times when you put your
foot down as a man and uh this is
definitely one of them although if you
got to this point it probably means that
you've never you've never put your foot
down one time and that's very obvious
from this you're leaving for
Thanksgiving dinner and you see your
wife holding a container of food
and I could see asking like oh is that
your contribution to the meal are you
bringing no that's just for me
uh oh you're joking right this is like a
crazy this is one of your crazy
practical jokes right that's very funny
no no I'm serious
okay well then you're a lunatic and I'm
calling in a sane Asylum I here's what
we're gonna do you put that damn
container down or I swear to God I will
have you admitted to an asylum put that
coffee down that's conflict resolution
in a marriage okay that's what you do
you at home
[Music]
uh first of all it says my husband and
then in parenthesis is Asian my husband
Asian and I American welcomed our
firstborn four weeks ago the baby is
healthy thank God but I'm exhausted my
husband's family had been pressuring us
to visit to meet the baby yesterday I
was surprised to find him standing on
the porch I was embarrassed and felt
like I wasn't ready for visitors because
the house was a n e s s y'all a mess
later I asked my husband if we should
order takeout for dinner he said no
because his parents would find this rude
and unwelcoming he suggested that I go
inside the kitchen and prepare something
I said fine then went and made some mac
and cheese once I served the family my
husband's mom asked if I really found it
appropriate to serve her and the family
mac and cheese
I hate macaroni and cheese we had an
argument and they decided to go home my
husband said that deciding to serve his
family mac and cheese was more offensive
than serving them nothing at all in my
the a-hole what's wrong with mac and
cheese wow okay
so this this husband I
here's the the note guys he's gonna help
me I gotta know Pat you want to give
your your wife like at least a week's
notice
if you're giving her a day it's gonna be
a problem but they're here right now the
house is a mess they can't you just you
can't do that you cannot do that if you
want to have a happy marriage you just
cannot do things like that then again
you know it's easy for me to say because
I'm never intent I'm never really
tempted to invite guests over for dinner
in the first place so that's not
something that ever really I never want
to do that anyway so I've never been
tempted in that direction but if I were
going to do it and on the on the rare
occasion when I do you know you could
never give too much notice if you could
give a Year's notice for that that's
probably best but I kind of like these
kinds of questions because this is one
where I get to say you're all a-holes
actually
you are all those now obviously your
mother-in-law and husband are a-holes uh
imposing yourself on somebody especially
a mother with a baby expecting a feast
one of my absolute unwavering
non-negotiable principles is that you
never complain
about food that has been served to you
this is why we don't have picky eaters
in my house okay picky eaters are a
social construct they are made not born
my kids will eat anything
anything we serve them because that's
the only option we've ever given them
finish your dessert and you are gonna
like it but I also have to unfortunately
give you a demerit for serving mac and
cheese yes they should have eaten it
without complaints but I can complain
because I'm not there so that I'm not
beholden to that rule and as an outside
Observer I can say that mac and cheese
is for children more mac and cheese yeah
just keep it going keep it going don't
be afraid of the burned edges just give
me the tray there should be no room on
an adult's plate for mac and cheese
there's so many better more
sophisticated side options so you're all
going to be a host for that one
[Music]
foreign
my two daughters are vegetarian but my
husband and son are not I'm probably
what they would call a flexitarian well
you're definitely the Apple I already
know that you're the [ __ ] based on
that alone a flexitarian so what does
that mean you're like you're flexible
you'll eat meat or vegetables is that
what you mean by Flex attack so you're
just a person you're a normal person
like all the rest of us you don't need
to come up with new labels for
everything you're not it's not you
didn't invent something new I'm a
fooditarian you know because I uh my my
thing is that I I eat food you know I
don't if it's not food I don't eat it
I'm a walk on the ground to tarian yeah
because I I generally I only walk on
things that are the ground
anyway
where were you my son and husband always
turn up their noses at tofu or any other
meat Alternatives they say it's just
weird that it's made to resemble real
meat so it's really the concept and not
the taste there are no allergies my
family and I often make two versions of
dinner one meat one real and twice the
amount of pots and pans there is an
equal distribution of cleaning and
cooking in this house thankfully my
daughters had a fun prank idea of making
two pots of spaghetti sauce under the
pretense that one was meat but they were
both the soy ground beef
the goal here was to see if their
brother and father actually hated the
meat that is the fake meat and to see if
we could maybe save some dishes and time
in the future everyone loved dinner both
husband and son finished their plates
this was when my youngest couldn't hold
it in anymore and told them they both
got very upset about being fed something
other than what they were told
Reddit am I the [ __ ] so they made soy
soy Meats which is not that's like
that's that doesn't actually exist just
like when they when you hear about
coconut milk or almond milk that's not
actually milk milk by definition is a
dairy product that's a coconut secretion
is what it should say on the carton
there's no such thing as soy meat that's
just it's fake so they made a soy thing
in two pots and they said that one was
meat and they said that they were
feeding that to the husband and son but
it was really the soy and they couldn't
tell the difference now Reddit has
declared that this woman is the uncle
yes you are the a-hole
goodbye you should never lie to somebody
about what you're feeding them so that
makes you an a-hole but
I actually think you're an a-hole for a
different reason you expect me to
believe
that you made a meat sauce
with soy beef and then your son and
husband who are big long time meat
eaters they couldn't tell that it wasn't
real meat that's [ __ ] sorry I just I
don't believe it that's
I've had meat substitutes before uh just
purely out of morbid curiosity and they
they always taste like a fertilizer and
sadness what does it taste like despair
okay they taste fraudulent always and by
the way if you have an ethical problem
with meat
then why are you eating food made to
taste like it that's the other thing I
don't understand I have a problem with
this I don't want to eat meat I think
it's immoral but I want my food to taste
like the thing that's immoral it just
doesn't make a lot of sense to me you
know sending data over an unencrypted
internet connection is like sending a
postcard your message is wide open for
the mailman and any other nosy
individual to see whenever you're
connected to an unencrypted internet
Network on your phone computer tablet or
TV you're sending countless pieces of
information out into the digital world
that can be seen and intercepted by
pretty much anyone a VPN creates a
secure tunnel between your device and
the Internet it's like putting your
postcard in an envelope so that no one
can read your letter before it gets the
person that you're sending it to
expressvpn is the VPN that I trust to
keep my data secure hackers they make
serious cash selling personal
information on the dark web but
expressvpn makes it easier than ever to
keep your information safe all you got
to do is fire up the app click one
button and you're instantly protected it
is as easy as that plus expressvpn works
on all your devices so you can stay
secure on the go so secure your online
data today at expressvpn.com
walshyt and get three extra months free
that's expressvpn.com
walshyt expressvpn.com
Walsh YT
[Music]
[Music]